welcome to machine learning tutorial
part 2 my name is Richard Kirchner with
the simply learned team that is w w
simply learn comm get certified get
ahead today in our second tutorial we're
gonna cover k-means and linear
regression along with going over the
quiz questions we had during our first
tutorial what's in it for you we're
gonna cover clustering what is
clustering k-means clustering which is
one of the most common used clustering
tools out there including a flowchart to
understand k-means clustering and how it
functions and that we'll do an actual
Python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands then we're gonna cover
logistic regression what is logistic
regression logistic regression curve and
sigmoid function and then we'll do
another Python code demo to classify a
tumor as malignant or benign based on
features let's start with clustering
suppose we have a pile of books of
different genres now we divide them into
different groups like fiction horror
education and as we can see from this
young lady she definitely is into heavy
horror you can just tell by those eyes
and the maple Canadian leaf on her shirt
but we have fiction horror and education
and we want to go ahead and divide our
books up well
organizing objects into groups based on
similarity is clustering and in this
case was we're looking at the books
we're talking about clustering things
with no.1 categories but you can also
use it to explore data so you might not
know the categories you just know that
you need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case we're gonna be
looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're gonna use k-means
clustering k-means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library k-means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to cluster into different
groups define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about
unsupervised learning and unlabeled data
so we don't know the answer yet we're
just gonna group stuff together and see
if we can find an answer of how things
connect we've also introduced feature
similarity features being different
features of the data now with books we
can easily see fiction and horror and
history books but a lot of times with
data some of that information isn't so
easy to see right when we first look at
it and so k-means is one of those tools
where we can start finding things that
connect that match with each other
suppose we have these data points and
want to assign them into a cluster now
when I look at these data points I would
probably group them into two clusters
just by looking at it I'd say two of
these group of data kind of come
together but in k-means we pick K
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the K clusters represents
two different clusters we pick K
clusters in psy random centroids to the
clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances and
calculate the centroids so we figure out
what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stopped changing their
positions and become static repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stopped changing and
the positions become static once the
clusters become static then k-means
clustering algorithm is said to be
converged when there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math were
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or its converged on an
answer shall we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy
step-by-step so we start we choose K
we'll look at the elbow method in just a
moment we assign random centroids to
clusters and sometimes you pick the
centroids because you might look at the
data and are in a graph and say oh these
are probably the central points then we
compute the distance from the objects to
the centroids we take that and we form
new clusters based on a minimum distance
and calculate their centroids then we
compute the distance from objects to the
new center
and then we go back and repeat those
last two steps we calculate the
distances so as we're doing it it brings
into the new centroid and then we move
the centroid around and we figure out
what the best which objects are closest
to each centroid so the objects can
switch from one centroid to the other
and the centroids are moved around and
we continue that until it is converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven individuals
and their score on two topics a and B so
here's our subject in this case
referring to the person taking the test
and then we have subject day where we
see what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject B and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initial cluster
centroids now remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points 1 & 1 & 5 & 7
and now let's take the two farthest
apart points as initial cluster
centroids each point is then assigned to
the closest cluster with respect to the
distance from the centroids so we take
each one of these points in there we
measure that distance and you can see
that if we made it each of those
distances and you use the Pythagorean
theorem for a triangle in this case
because you know the X and the y and you
can figure out the diagonal line from
that or you just take a ruler and put it
on your monitor that'd be kind of silly
but it would work if you're just
eyeballing it you can see how they
naturally come together in certain areas
now we again calculate the centroids of
each cluster so cluster 1 and then
cluster 2 and we look at each individual
dot there's 1 2 3 we're in one cluster
the centroid then moves over it becomes
1 point 8 comma 2 point 3 so remember it
was at 1 & 1
well the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly to 2 but 1 point 8 and 2 point 3
and the second one if we wanted to make
the overall mean vector the average
vector of all the different distances to
that centroid we come up with 4 comma 1
and 5/4 so we've now moved the SCIM
Freud's we compare each individual's
distance to its own cluster mean and to
that of the opposite cluster and we find
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move that centroid around we now have
a new different kind of clustering of
groups and using euclidean distance
between the points and the mean we get
the same formula you see as new formulas
coming up so we have our individual dots
distance to the mean centroid of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster only individual
three is nearer to the mean of the
opposite cluster cluster two then its
own cluster one and you can see here in
the diagram where we've kind of circled
that one in the middle so when we've
moved the clusters the centroids of the
cluster is over one of the points
shifted to the other cluster because
it's closer to that group of individuals
thus individual three is relocated to
cluster two resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters for the new clusters we will
find the actual cluster centroids so now
we move the centroids over and you can
see that we now form two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individuals distance to
its own cluster mean and to that of the
opposite cluster we find that the data
points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember I
brought up a concept earlier caming on
the k-means algorithm choosing the right
value of k will help in less number of
iterations and to find the appropriate
number of clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares WS s is defined as the sum of
the squared distance between each member
of the cluster and its centroid and so
you see we've done here is we have the
number of clusters and as you do the
same k-means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
finally optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method and on this we guessed at two
just by looking at the data but as you
can see the slope you actually just look
for right there where the elbow is in
the slope and you have a clear answer
that we want to different to start with
k-means equals to a lot of times people
end up computing k-means equals to three
four or five until they find the value
which
fits on the elbow joint sometimes you
can just look at the data and if you're
really good with that specific domain
remember domain I mentioned that last
time you'll know that that where to pick
those numbers where to start guessing at
what that K value is so let's take this
line we're going to use a use case using
k-means clustering to cluster cars into
brands using parameters such as
horsepower cubic inches make year etc so
we're going to use the data set cars
data having information about three
brands of cars Toyota Honda and Nissan
we'll go back to my favorite tool the
anaconda navigator with the jupiter
notebook and let's go ahead and flip
over to our Jupiter notebook and in our
Jupiter notebook I'm gonna go ahead and
just paste the basic code that we
usually started a lot of these off with
we're not going to go too much into this
code because we've already discussed
numpy we've already discussed map plot
library and pandas and they'll be being
the number of red pandas being the
pandas dataframe and mat plot for the
graphing and don't forget since if
you're using the Jupiter notebook you do
need the map plot library in line so
that it plots everything on the screen
if you're using a different Python
editor then you probably don't need that
because it'll have a pop-up window in
your computer I will go ahead and run
this just to load our libraries and our
setup into here the next step is a
course to look at our data which I've
already opened up in a spreadsheet and
you can see here we have the miles per
gallon cylinders cubic inches horsepower
weight pounds
I don't know how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60 my cart is probably
on this one at about 80 or 90 what year
it is so this is you can actually see
this is kind of older cars and then the
brand Toyota Honda Nissan so the
different cars are coming from all the
way from 1971 if we scroll down to the
80s we have between the 70s and 80s a
number of cars that they've put out and
that's we come back here we're gonna do
importing the data so we'll go ahead and
do data set equals I will use pandas to
read this in and it's from a CSV file
remember you can always post this in the
comments and request the data files for
these either in the comments here on the
YouTube video or go to
simply learn calm and request that the
cars CSV I put it in the same folder as
the code that I've stored so my Python
code is stored in the same folder so I
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double-check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because you know it's a data
set we're importing and we've now
imported our cars CSV into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the X data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there is a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
4i and X dot columns so we're going to
go through each of the columns and a lot
of times it's important I'll make lists
of the columns and do this because I
might remove certain columns or there
might be comms that I want to be
processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take X of I and we want
to go fill n/a and that's a panda's
command but the question is what we're
going to fill the missing data with we
definitely don't want to just put in a
number that doesn't actually mean
something and so one of the tricks you
can do with this is we can take X of I
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into an integer so a
lot of these are integers so we'll go
ahead and keep it integers and we add
the bracket here and a lot of editors
will do this they'll think that you're
closing one bracket make sure you get
that second bracket in there if it's a
double bracket that's always something
that happens regularly so once we have
our integer of X of Y this is gonna fill
in any missing data with the average and
I was so busy closing one set of
brackets I forgot that the mean is also
has brackets in there for the pandas so
we can see here we're going to fill in
all the data with the average value for
that column so there's missing data and
the average of the data it does have
then once we've done that I'll go ahead
and loop through it again and just check
and see to make sure everything is
filled in correctly well print and then
we take X is null and this returns a set
of the null value or the how many lines
are null and we'll just sum that up just
see what that looks like and so what
run this so with the X what we want to
do is we want to remove the last column
because it had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the X out for one we could take the X we
could go data set our variable we're
using and use the I location one of the
features that's in pandas and we could
take that and then take all the rows and
all but the last column of the data set
and at this time we could do values we
just convert it to values so that's one
way to do this and if I let me just put
this down here and print X it's a
capital X we chose and I run this you
can see it's just the values we could
also take out the values and it's not
gonna return anything because there's no
values connected to it what I like to do
with this is instead of doing the I
location which does integers more common
is to come in here and we have our data
set and we're gonna do data set dot or
data set dot columns and remember that
lists all the columns so if I come in
here let me just mark that as red and I
print data set Dadar columns you can see
that I have my index here I have my MPG
cylinders everything including the brand
which we don't want so the way to get
rid of the brand would be to do data
columns of everything with the last one
minus one so now if I print this you'll
see the brand disappears and so I can
actually just take data set columns
minus one and I'll put it right in here
for the columns we're gonna look at and
let's unmarked this and unmarked this
and now if I do an X dot head I'd have a
new data frame and you can see right
here we have all the different columns
except for the brand at the end of the
year and it turns out when you start
playing with the data set you're gonna
get an error later on and it'll say
cannot convert string to float value and
that's big
because for some reason these things the
way they recorded them must been
recorded as strings so we have a neat
feature in here on pandas to convert and
it is simply convert objects and for
this we're gonna do convert oops convert
underscore numeric numeric equals true
and yes I did have to go look that up I
don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if I'm working with a
lot of these things I remember them but
depending on where I'm at what I'm doing
I usually have to look it up and we run
that oops I must have missed something
in here let me double check my spelling
and when I double check my spelling
you'll see I missed the first underscore
and the convert objects when I run this
it now has everything converted into a
numeric value because that's what we're
going to be working with is numeric
values down here and the next part is
that we need to go through the data and
eliminate null values most people when
they're doing small amounts you're
working with small data pools discover
afterwards that they have a null value
and have to go back and do this so you
know be aware whenever we're formatting
this data things are gonna pop up and
sometimes you go backwards to fix it and
that's fine that's just part of
exploring the date and understanding
what you have then I should have done
this earlier but let me go ahead and
increase the size of my window one
knotch
there we go
easier to see so we'll do for i in
working with X dot columns will page
through all the columns and we want to
take X of I we're gonna change that
we're gonna alter it and so with this we
want to go ahead and fill in X so I
pandas has the fill in a and that just
fills in any non-existent missing data
we'll put my brackets up and there's a
lot of different ways to fill this data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
if and then look at it later in a
separate exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our column and we can find the
means and the means is in there are
quotation marks so we take the cause
we're going to fill in the non-existing
one with the means the problem is that
returns a decimal float so some of these
aren't decimals certainly need to be a
little careful of doing this but for
this example we're just going to fill it
in with the integer version of this
keeps it on par with the other data that
isn't a decimal point
and then we also want to do is we want
to double-check a lot of times you do
this first part first to double-check
then you do the fill and you do it again
just to make sure you did it right
so we're going to go through and test
for missing data and one of the ways you
can do that simply go in here and take
our X of I column so it's going to go
through the X of I comma says is null
just gonna return any place there's a
null value it actually goes through the
all the rows of each column is null and
then we want to go ahead and sum that so
we take that and we add the some value
and these are all pandas so is known as
a Panda command and so is some and if we
go through that we go ahead and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns are have
zero null values
so we've now tested and double-checked
and our data is nice and clean we have
no null values everything is now a
number value we turned it into numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data and at this point we're actually
going to start using the elbow method to
find the optimal number of clusters so
we're now actually getting into the SK
learn part the k-means clustering on
here I guess we'll go ahead and zoom it
up one more not so you can see what I'm
typing in here and then from SK learn or
SK learn cluster I'm going to import
k-means I always forget to capitalize
the K in the M when I do this so its
capital K capital M k-means and we'll go
ahead and create a ray W CSS equals when
we could an empty array if you remember
from the elbow method from our slide
within the sums of squares WS s is
defined as the sum of squared distance
between each member of the cluster in a
centroid so we're looking at that change
in differences as far as a squared
distance and we're gonna run this over a
number of K mean values in fact let's go
for I and Range will do 11 of them
Marine 0 11 and the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to create the
actual fluid all lowercase so we create
this object from the k-means that we
just imported and the variable that we
want to put into this is in clusters
we're gonna set that equals to I that's
the most important one because we're
looking at how increasing the number of
clusters changes our answer there are a
lot of settings to the k-means our guys
in the back did a great job I'm just
kind of playing with some of them the
most common ones that you see in a lot
of stuff is how you would knit your
k-means so we have k-means plus plus
plus this is just a tool to let the
model itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial in
sin droids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times here the max
iteration we put in there we have on the
infinite the random state equals zero
you really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this as you start digging in deeper you
start finding that these are shortcuts
that will speed up the process as far as
a set up but the big one that we're
working with is the in clusters equals I
so we're going to literally train our
k-means eleven times we're gonna do this
process 11 times and if you're working
with big data you know the first thing
you do is you run a small sample of the
data so you can test all your stuff on
it and you can already see the problem
that if I'm going to iterate through a
terabyte of data 11 times and then the
k-means itself is iterating through the
data multiple times that's a heck of a
process so you got to be a little
careful with this a lot of times though
you can find your elbow using the elbow
method find your optimal number on a
sample of data especially if you're
working with larger data sources so we
want to go ahead and take our k-means
and we're just gonna fit it if you're
looking at any of the SK learn very
common that you fit your model if you
remember correctly our variable we're
using is the capital X and once we fit
this value we go back to the array we
made and we want to go and just to pin
that value on the end and it's not the
actual fit we're pinning in there it's
when it generates it it generates the
value you're looking for is inertia so K
means not inertia will pull that
specific value out that we need and
let's get a visual on this we'll do our
PLT plot and what we're plotting here
is first the x-axis which has range
0:11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there and the WCS s for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
yeah let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do PL
T X label and we'll do number of
clusters for that and PLT Y label and
for that we can do W CSS since that's
what we're doing on the plot on there
and finally we want to go ahead and
display our graph which is simply PLT
that's show there we go
and because we have it set to inline
he'll appear in line if they didn't make
a type error on there and you can see we
get a very nice graph you can see a very
nice elbow joint there at 2:00 and again
right around 3 & 4 and then after that
there's not very much now as a data
scientist if I was looking at this I
would do either 3 or 4 and I'd actually
tried both of them to see what the
output look like
and they've already tried this in the
back so we're just gonna use 3 as a set
up on here and let's go ahead and see
what that looks like when we actually
use this to show the different kinds of
cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars data set and
basically we're gonna copy the code that
we looped through up above where k-means
equals k means number of clusters and
we're just going to set the number of
clusters to three you since that's what
we're gonna look for and you can do
three and four on this and graph them
just to see how they come up differently
be kind of curious to look at that but
for this we're just gonna set it to
three go ahead and create our own
variable y k means for our answers and
we're gonna set that equal to whoops
double their two k-means but we're not
gonna do a fit we're gonna do a fit
predict is the setup you want to use and
when you're using untrained models
you'll see a slightly different is
usually see fit and then you see just
the predict but we want to both fit and
predict the k-means on this and that's
fit underscore predict and then our
capital x is the data we're working with
and before we plot this data we're gonna
do a little pandas trick and we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set X s matrix so we're converting this
into a nice rows and columns kind of set
up but we want the we're gonna have
columns equals none so it's just gonna
be a matrix of data in here and let's go
ahead and run that a little warning
you'll see his warnings pop up because
things are always being updated so
there's like minor changes in the
versions and future versions let's set a
matrix now that it's more common to set
it values instead of doing as matrix but
mass matrix works just fine for right
now you'll want to update that later on
but let's go ahead and dive in and plot
this and see what that looks like and
before we dive into plotting this data I
always like to take a look and see what
I am plotting so let's take a look at
why k-means I'm just going to print that
out down here and we see we have an
array of answers we have two one zero
two one two so its clustering these
different rows of data based on the
three different spaces it thinks it's
going to be and then let's go ahead and
print X and see what we have for X and
we'll see that X is an
it's a matrix so we have our different
values in the array and what we're going
to do it's very hard to plot all the
different values in the array so we're
only going to be looking at the first
two or position zero and one and if you
were doing a full presentation in front
of the board meeting you might actually
do a little different than dig a little
deeper into the different aspects
because this is all the different
columns we looked at but we'll look at
columns 1 & 2 for this to make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so PLT scatter and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this we're
going to take the X values and we're
only interested in Y of K means equals
zero the first cluster okay and then
we're going to take value 0 for the x
axes and then we can do the same thing
here we're only interested in K means
equal 0 but we're going to take this
second column so we're looking at the
first two columns in our answer or in
the data and then the guys in the back
plate with this a little bit to make it
pretty and they discovered that it looks
good with as a size equals 100 that's
the size of the dots we're gonna use red
for this one and when they were looking
at the data and what came out it was
definitely the Toyota on this we're just
gonna go and label it Toyota
again that's something you'd really have
to explore in here as far as playing
with those numbers and see what looks
good we'll go ahead and hit enter in
there and I'm just gonna paste in the
next two lines which is the next two
cars and this is our Nisa and Honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where y underscore K
means equals one and we want the zero
column and YK means equals two again
we're looking at just the first two
columns zero and one and each of these
rows then corresponds to Nissan and
Honda and I'll go ahead and hit enter on
there and finally let's take a look and
put the centroids on there again we're
going to do a scatter plot
the centroids you can just pull that
from our k-means the model we created
dot cluster centers and we're gonna just
do all of them in the first number and
all of them in the second number which
is zero one because you always start
with zero and one and then they were
playing with the size and everything to
make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're gonna make
the color yellow and blue label them so
he's going to have some good labels
centroids and then we do want to do a
title fill T title and pop up there
PLT title so you always make one week
your graphs look pretty and we'll call
it clusters of car make and one of the
features of the plot library is you can
add a legend you'll automatically bring
in it since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
Toyota Nissan and Honda and finally we
want to go ahead and show so we can
actually see it and remember it's in
line so if using a different editor
that's not the Jupiter notebook you'll
get a pop up of this and you should have
a nice set of clusters here so we can
look at this we have a clusters of Honda
and green Toyota and red Nissan and
purple and you can see where they put
the centroids to separate them now when
we're looking at this we can also plot a
lot of other different data on here as
far because we only looked at the first
two columns this is just column 1 and 2
or a 0 1 as you label them in computer
scripting but you can see here we have a
nice clusters of car making we were able
to pull out the data and you can see how
just these two columns form very
distinct clusters of data so if you were
exploring new data you might take a look
and say well what makes these different
almost going in Reverse you start
looking at the date and pulling apart
the columns to find out why is the first
group set up the way it is maybe you're
doing loans you wanna go well why is
this group not defaulting on their loans
and why is the last group defaulting on
their loans and why is the middle group
50% defaulting on their bank loans and
you start finding ways to manipulate the
data and pull out the answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use K
mean for clustering let's move on to the
next topic now let's look into logistic
regression the logistic regression
algorithm is the simplest classification
algorithm used for binary or multi
classification problems and we can see
we have our little girl from Canada
who's into horror books is back that's
actually really scary when you think
about that with those big eyes in the
previous tutorial we learned about
linear regression dependent and
independent variables so to brush-up y
equals MX plus C very basic algebraic
function of Y and X the dependent
variable is the target class variable we
are going to predict the independent
variables x1 all the way up to xn are
the features or attributes we're going
to use to predict the target class we
know what a linear regression looks like
but using the graph we cannot divide the
outcome into categories he is really
hard to categorize one point five three
point six nine point eight for example a
linear regression graph can tell us that
with increase in number of hours studied
the marks of a student will increase but
it will not tell us whether the student
will pass or not in such cases where we
need the output is categorical value we
will use logistic regression and for
that we're going to use the sigmoid
function so you can see here we have our
marks zero to a hundred number of our
studied that's going to be what they're
comparing it to in this example and we
usually form a line this as y equals MX
plus C and when we use the sigmoid
function we have P equals 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus y it generates a sigmoid
curve and so you can see right here when
you take the Ln which is the natural
logarithm I always thought it should be
in L not Ln that's just the inverse of e
or e to the minus y and so we do this we
get Ln of P over 1 minus P equals M
times X plus C that's the sigmoid curve
function we're looking for and we can
zoom in on the function and you'll see
that the function is it derives goes to
one or two
zero depending on what your x value is
and the probability if it's greater than
0.5 the value is automatically run it
off to 1 indicating that the student
will pass so if they're doing a certain
amount of studying they will probably
pass then you have a threshold value at
the point 5 it automatically puts it
right in the middle usually and your
probability if it's less than 0.5 the
value rendered off to zero indicating
the student will fail so if they're not
studying very hard they're probably
going to fail this of course is ignoring
the outliers or that one student is just
a natural genius and doesn't need any
studying to memorize everything that's
not me unfortunately have to study hard
to learn new stuff problem statement to
classify whether a tumor is malignant or
benign and this is actually one of my
favorite datasets to play with because
it has so many features and when you
look at them you really are hard to
understand you can't just look at them
and know the answer so it gives you a
chance to kind of dive into what data
looks like when you aren't able to
understand the specific domain of the
data but I also want to remind you that
in the domain of medicine if I told you
that my probability was really good it
classified things that say 90 percent or
95 percent and I'm classifying whether
you're gonna have a malignant or a
benign tumor I'm guessing that you're
gonna go get it tested anyways so you
got to remember the domain we're working
with so why would you want to do that if
you know you're just gonna go get a
biopsy because you know it's that
serious this is like an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor know
where to look just by understanding what
kind of tumor it is so it might help
them or aid them and something they
missed from before so let's go ahead and
dive into the code it'll come back to
the domain part of it in just a minute
so use case and we're gonna do our
normal imports here or importing numpy
pandas Seabourn the mat plot library and
we're gonna do Matt plot library in line
since I'm going to switch over to
anaconda so let's go ahead and flip over
there and get this started so I've
opened up a new window in my anaconda
Jupiter notebook and by the way Jupiter
notebook you don't have to use anaconda
for the Jupiter notebook I just love the
inner
and all the tools in anaconda brings so
we got our import numpy as in p4 our
numpy number array we have our pandas PD
we're gonna bring in Seaborn to help us
with our graphs as SNS so many really
nice tools in both Seaborn and mat plot
library then we'll do our map plot
library type I plot as PLT and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set up and we're just gonna
call our data data not creative today
equals PD and this happens to be in a
CSV file so we'll use a PD read
underscore CSV and I happen to name the
file I renamed it data for p2 dot CSV
you can of course write in the comments
below the YouTube and request for the
data set itself or go to the simply
learned website and we'll be happy to
supply that for you and let's just um
open up the data before we go any
further and let's just see what it looks
like in a spreadsheet so when I pop it
open in a local spreadsheet and this is
just a CSV file comma separated
variables we have an ID so I guess the
categorizes for reference or what ID
which test was done the diagnosis M for
malignant B for benign s there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're gonna try to predict is the M
and B and test it and then we have like
the radius mean or average the texture
average perimeter mean area mean
smoothness I don't know about you but
unless you're a doctor in the field most
of stuff I mean you can guess what
concave means just by the term concave I
really wouldn't know what that means and
the measurements are taking so they have
all kinds of stuff like how smooth it is
the symmetry and these are all float
values you can just page through them
real quick and you'll see there's I
believe 36 if I remember correctly in
this one so there's a lot of different
values they take in all these
measurements they take when they go in
there and they take a look at the
different growth the tumorous growth so
back in our data and I put this in the
same folder as a code so I saved this
code in that folder obviously if you
have it in a different location you want
to put the full path in there and we'll
just do hand
is first five lines of data with the
date ahead and we run that we can see
that we have pretty much what we just
looked at we have an ID we have a
diagnosis if we go all the way across
you'll see all the different columns
coming across displayed nicely for our
data and while we're exploring the data
our Seabourn which we referenced as SNS
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice that very
similar to because it is sitting on top
of the plot library so the joint plot
does a lot of work for us and we're just
gonna look at the first two columns that
we're interested in the radius mean and
the texture mean we'll just look at
those two columns and data equals data
so that tells it which two columns were
plotting and then we're gonna use the
data that we pulled in let's just run
that and it generates a really nice
graph on here and there's all kinds of
cool things on this graph to look at I
mean we have the texture meaning the
radius mean obviously the axes you can
also see and one of the cool things on
here is you can also see the histogram
they show that for the radius mean where
is the most common Sree Dias mean come
up and where the most common texture is
us we're looking at the tech the on each
growth its average texture and on each
radius its average radius on there it's
a little confusing because we're talking
about the individual objects average and
then we can also look over here and see
the histogram showing us the median or
how common each measurement is and
that's only two columns so let's dig a
little deeper into Seabourn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map
I guess the original ones were plotting
heat density on something and so ever
since then it's just called a heat map
and we're gonna take our data and get
our corresponding numbers to put that
into the heat map and that's simply data
dot cor R for that that's a panda's
expression let's remember we're working
in a panda's data frame so that's one of
the cool tools and pandas for our data
and this is pull that information into a
heat map
and see what that looks like and you'll
see that we're now looking at all the
different features we have our ID we
have our texture we have our area our
compactness concave points and if you
look down the middle of this chart
diagonal going from the upper left of
bottom right it's all white that's
because when you compare texture to
texture they're identical so there are a
hundred percent or in this case perfect
one in their correspondence and you'll
see that when you look at say area or
right below it it has almost a black on
there when you compare it to texture so
these have almost no corresponding data
they don't really form a linear graph or
something that you can look at and say
how connected they are they're very
scattered data this is really just a
really nice craft to get a quick look at
your data doesn't so much change what
you do but it changes verifying so when
you get an answer or something like that
or you start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're gonna
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but just show some really cool
information on here I mean we can see
from the ID there's no real one feature
that just says if you go across the top
line that lights up there's no one
feature that says hey if the area is a
certain size then it's gonna be benign
or malignant it says there's some that
sort of add up and that's a big hint in
the data that we're trying to ID this
whether it's malignant or benign that's
a big hint test as data scientist to go
okay we can't solve this with any one
feature it's going to be something that
includes all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data
let's explore one more area and let's
look at data is null we want to check
for null values in our data if you
remember from earlier in this tutorial
we did it a little differently where we
added stuff up and summing them up you
can actually with pandas do it really
quickly data is null and summit and it's
going to go across all the columns so
when I run this
you're gonna see all that columns come
up with no null data so we've just just
to rehash these last few steps we've
done a lot of exploration we have looked
at the first two columns and seeing how
they plot with the Seabourn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram and the data plotted on the XY
coordinates and obviously you can do
that more in detail with different
columns and see how they plot together
and then we took and did the Seabourn
heat map the SNS dot heat map of the
data and you can see right here where
did a nice job showing us some bright
spots where stuff correlates with each
other it forms a very nice combination
or points of scattering points and you
can also see areas that don't and then
finally we went ahead and checked the
data is the data a null value do we have
any missing data in there very important
step because they'll crash later on if
you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says null values okay so not a
big deal if you miss it but it's no fun
having to go back when you're you're in
a huge process and you've missed this
step and now you're ten steps later and
you gotta go remember where you were
pulling the data in so we need to go
ahead and pull out our X and our Y let
me just put that down here and we'll set
the X equal to and there's a lot of
different options here certainly we
could do x equals all the columns except
for the first two because if you
remember the first two is the ID and the
diagnosis so that certainly would be an
option but we're going to do is we're
actually going to focus on the worst the
worst radius the worst texture parameter
area smoothness compactness and so on
one of the reasons to start dividing
your data up when you're looking at this
information is sometimes the data will
be the same data coming in so if I have
two measurements coming in to my model
it might over weigh them it might
overpower the other measurements because
it's measure it's basically taking that
information in twice that's a little bit
past the scope of this tutorial I want
you to take away from this though is
we are dividing the data up into pieces
and our team in the back went ahead and
said hey let's just look at the worst so
I'm gonna create a array and you'll see
this array radius worst texture worst
perimeter worst we've just taken the
worst of the worst
and I'm just going to put that in my X
so this X is still a panda's data frame
but it's just those columns and our Y if
you remember correctly it's gonna be
oops hold on one second it's not axis
data there we go so x equals data and
then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst and if
we're going to take that then we have to
have our answer for our y for the stuff
we know and if you remember quickly
we're just going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it benign or
malignant
and since it's a single column we can
just do diagnosis I forget to put the
brackets or there we go okay so it's
just diagnosis on there and we can also
real quickly do like X dot head if you
want to see what that looks like and why
dot head and run this and you'll see it
only does the last one I forgot about
that if you don't do print you can see
that the the Y dot head is just mmm
because the first ones are all malignant
and if I run this the X dot head it's
just the first five values of radius
worst texture worst parameter worst area
worst and so on I'm going to take that
out so moving down to the next step
we've built our two data sets our answer
and then the features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your model so we do that by
splitting the data
and from SK learned model selection
we're going to import train tests split
so we're gonna split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this I
noticed in one of the more modern ways
they actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
but just past the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just gonna split it into
two groups one to train our data and one
to test our data and the SK learn Dalton
we have train tests split you could
write your own quick code to do this we
just randomly divide the data up into
two groups but they do it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate for
variables capital X train capital X
tests so we have our training data we're
going to use to fit the model and then
we need something to test it and then we
have our wide train so we're gonna trade
the answer and then we have our test so
this is the stuff we want to see how
good it did on our model and we'll go
ahead and take our train test split that
we just imported and we're gonna do X
and our Y or two different data that's
going in for our split and then the guys
in the back came up and wanted us to go
ahead and use a test size equals 0.3
that's test underscore size random state
it's always nice to kind of switch your
random state around but not that
important
what this means is that the test size is
we're gonna take 30 percent of the data
and we're gonna put that into our test
variables or Y tests and our X tests and
we're gonna do 70 percent into the X
train and the white rain so we're gonna
use 70 percent of the data to train our
model and 30 percent to test it let's go
ahead and run that and load those up so
now we have all our stuff split up and
all our data ready to go and now we get
to the actual logistics part we're
actually going to do our create our
model so let's go ahead and bring that
in from SK learn we're gonna bring in
our linear model and we're going to
import logistic regression that's the
actual model we're using and this it'll
call it log model
it's the model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just import it so now we have a variable
log model set to that class for us to
use and with most the models in the SK
learned we just need to go ahead and fix
it fit do a fit on there and we use our
X train that we separate it out with our
Y train now let's go ahead and run this
so once we've run this we'll have a
model that fits this data that's 70% of
our training data and of course the
prints this out that tells us all the
different variables you can set on there
there's a lot of different choices you
can make
but for word no we're just gonna let all
the defaults sit we don't really need to
mess with those on this particular
example there's nothing in here that
really stands out is super important
until you start fine-tuning it but for
what we're doing the basics will work
just fine and then let's we need to go
ahead and test out our model is it
working so let's create a variable Y
predict and this is going to be equal to
our log model and we want to do a
predict again very standard format for
the SK learn library is taking your
model and doing a predict on it and
we're gonna test Y predict against the Y
test so we want to know what the model
thinks it's going to be that's what our
y predict is and with that we want the
capital X X test so we have our train
set and our test set and now we're going
to do our y predict let's go ahead and
run that and if we print
why predict let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it pretends
and I prints a nice array of B and M for
benign and malignant for all the
different test data we put in there so
that's pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science that as
you explore this you spend a significant
amount of time prepping your data and
making sure your data coming in is good
there's a saying good data in good
answers out bad data in bad answers out
that's only half the thing that's only
half of it selecting your models becomes
the next part as far as how good your
models are and then of course fine
tuning it depending on what model you're
using so we come in here we want to know
how good this came out so we have our y
predict here log model to predict X test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the SK learned
metrics we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model is doing and
then we're going to feed it the model
data and this is print this out and
we'll take our classification report and
we're going to put into there
our tests are actual data so this is
what we actually know is true and our
prediction what our model predicted for
that data on the test side and let's run
that and see what that does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have a precision for benign and
malignant B&M and we have a precision of
93 and 91 a total of 92 so it's kind of
the average between these two 92 there's
all kinds of different information on
here your f1 score your recall your
support coming through on this and for
this I'll go ahead and just flip back to
our slides that they put together for
describing it and so here we're going to
look at the precision using the
classification report and you see this
is the same printout I had up above some
of them are numbers might be different
because it does randomly pick out which
data we're using so this model is able
to predict the type of tumor with 91%
accuracy so we look back here that's
you'll see where we have benign
malignant it actually is 92 coming up
here but we're looking about a 90 to 91
percent precision now remember I
reminded you about domain so we're
talking about the domain of a medical
domain with a very catastrophic outcome
you know at 91 or 92 percent precision
you're still gonna go in there and have
somebody do a biopsy on it very
different than if you're investing money
and there's a 92 percent chance you're
gonna earn 10% and a percent chance
you're gonna lose 8%
you're probably gonna bet the money
because if that odds is pretty good that
you'll make some money and in the long
run you do that enough you definitely
will make money and also with this
domain I've actually seen them use this
to identify different forms of cancer
that's one of the things that they're
starting to use these models for because
then it helps a doctor know what to
investigate so that wraps up this
section we're finally we're gonna go in
there and let's discuss the answer to
the quiz asked in machine learning
tutorial part 1 can you tell what's
happening in the following cases
grouping documents into different
categories based on the topic and
content of each document this is an
example of clustering where k-means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using bag-of-words
approach so if you've got in there that
you're looking for clustering and
hopefully you had at least one or two
examples like k-means that are used for
clustering different things then give
yourself a two thumbs up be
identifying handwritten digits and
images correctly this is an example of
classification the traditional approach
to solving this would be to extract
digit dependent features like curvature
of different digits etc and then use a
classifier like SVM to distinguish
between images again if you got the fact
that it's a classification example give
yourself a thumb up and if you're able
to go hey let's use SVM or another model
for this give yourself those two thumbs
up on it see behavior of a website
indicating that the site is not working
as designed this is an example of
anomaly detection in this case the
algorithm learns what is normal and what
is not normal usually by observing the
logs or the website give yourself a
thumbs up if you got that one and just
for a bonus can you think of another
example of anomaly detection one of the
ones I use it for my own business is
detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very fickle and they
behave very radical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic with
something released in social media was
something released you can see we're
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual and if you guess if this was
a regression model give yourself a
thumbs up and if you're able to remember
that it was between independent and
dependent variables and that terms give
yourself two thumbs up summary so to
wrap it up we went over what is k-means
and we went through also the chart of
choosing your elbow method and assigning
a random centroid to the clusters
computing the distance and then going in
there and figuring out what the minimum
of centroids is and computing the
distance and going through that loop
until it gets the perfect centroid and
we looked into the elbow method to
choose K based on running our clusters
across a number of variables and finding
the best location for that we did a nice
example of clustering cars with k-means
even though we only looked at the first
two column
to make it simple and easy to graph you
can easily extrapolate that and look at
all the different columns and see how
they all fit together and we looked at
what is a logistic regression we
discussed the sigmoid function what is
logistic regression and then we went
into an example of classifying tumors
with logistics I hope you enjoyed part
two a machine-learning thank you for
joining us today for more information
visit www.mptv.org/outdoorwisconsin to
learn calm will be happy to supply you
with the datasets or other information
as requested hi there if you liked this
video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos Dinard up and get
certified
click here